I hated my grad school professor for a very long time.
on the first day of grad school,
she was like,
everybody state your zip codes.
and at first I was like, okay,
that's weird. why?
but I later found out that each of us in the classroom
would find out our life expectancy,
our career trajectory,
the probability of us getting some sort of diseases
like diabetes or cardiovascular disease.
and it was honestly an eerie experience
to sit next to some of your classmates
and realize that you had, like,
10 more years of life expectancy
compared to other people
just based on your zip code.
and you could live, like,
10 or 15 miles away from each other.
fast forward to the end of the program.
I graduated with a 3.96,
and I only got one a minus.
it was in her class.
see why I didn't really like her?
anyway, I went to her after finishing my final project,
which was an essay,
and I asked her,
why did I get to be on this paper?
and I compared myself, actually,
to some of my classmates
who got a higher grade than I did.
and I knew, because I worked with them in group projects,
that they weren't as good writers.
not even trying to be shady or anything,
they just weren't.
and she said,
you're an exquisite writer,
but not everybody has had the same access
to the educational systems that you have.
had access. to.
in that moment,
I was shocked,
but it kind of finally hit me
that she was trying to teach
and create an equitable teaching environment.
if you're not sure what equity and education is,
it's this picture right here.
perfect way to explain it.
anyway, what's the point of what I'm saying?
that class changed my entire life.
that whole graduate program changed my entire life.
my perspective,
my understanding of equality and equity
and what I can do as an individual to
make more equitable situations.
which is why every week
I host a career forum
where people can go live with me
and ask specific career questions.
because I realize that
even though I do give general career advice,
it may be difficult for some people
to extract that information
and apply it to their personal situations
if they just.
just simply don't know how.
today is MLK day,
and, yes, most,
if not all, of us have the day off.
and what you should do is, I hope,
spend the day reflecting on how you can contribute
to making more situations in your field,
your industry, whatever,
more equitable for others.